here's the first thing we just need to
boot it out of the way okay we share a
love of the goddess that is Meryl Streep
well I feel like does anybody does
anybody not have my love and if so they
need to see a doctor because I am 30
stars away from her on I'm pretty bad
that is crazy he just dropped that I
[Laughter]
love her and you got to work with her
and retain the flash I do she was a
singer first yes she was younger coming
when she whips that out it's it's the
best when we get to see like Mamma Mia
into the woods yeah it's amazing two
scenes with her and I movie I was just
too terrified the whole time to even
really like take her in but then she
came to see Jeremy Hanson which was the
show that I was doing in New York
[Applause]
completely like I added like an extra
voice lesson that week like a new
haircut like I really I got prepare
because I got warning but she was coming
so I would not want to know oh I have to
know I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this